hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the monday morning podcast for
monday
february 21st
2022
how the hell are you what's going on in
your world
it's omar what's the dead a [ __ ]
winner
back east oh jesus christ
snowing all over the place you know for
some reason i didn't remember i don't
even remember why
which is why i initially said for some
reason and then i figured in case you
weren't familiar with that expression
i would then say in case you don't
remember why
um
i was looking up this [ __ ] on uh the
great lakes
i don't know why
for the 50th time
i don't even remember what it was but
they were talking about how they can
actually have hurricanes
ah jesus bill you know only you only you
would bring up some [ __ ] that you can't
remember
um
great
lakes
hurricane
1913. here we go they had this [ __ ]
hurricane
in 1913 this is before the weather
channel
or even like radio
or even that thing
maybe they had that morse code get the
[ __ ] out of the [ __ ] water they
didn't have any of that [ __ ]
the great lake storm of 1913
historically referred to as the big
[ __ ] blow
or freshwater fury
and the white hurricane the great white
hope the white hurricane
uh was a blizzard
with hurricane force winds that
devastated the great lakes basin
in the midwestern united states and
southwestern ontario canada from
november 7th to november 10th in
1913 the storm was most powerful on
november 9th battering and overturning
ships on four of the five great lakes
particularly
lake
huron
now like huron doesn't get a lot of
doesn't get you know everybody knows
lake michigan that's but night there was
chicago my kind of town chicago is
a lot of racism chicago is
keeping people separate chicago is
eating more than your [ __ ] chair
sorry
um and then lake erie
because everybody thinks that caught on
fire in cleveland when it was really
like an inlet
and then you got uh lake ontario of
course the lake ontario playhouse
the ontario senators
the ottawa senator sorry then you got
lake superior everybody remembers that
because you know thinks it's better than
everybody else and then like the [ __ ]
odd man out
you know
it's like that other manning brother
that never played football or they only
got hurt
it's like huron
lake huron particularly on lake huron
the storm is deadliest and most
destructive net was the most deadliest
natural uh and destructive natural
disaster to hit the lakes and recorded
history more than 250 people were killed
all right no smartphones no weather
channel all you had was some old guy
talking about how his [ __ ] big toe
was acting up
and then he had to look at him like is
his big toe acting up because he's
[ __ ] old or does that mean there's a
hurricane coming
i don't know i say we take a shot right
and then they go out in the lake and
they never heard from again
uh shipping was hardest hit 19 ships
were destroyed and 19 others were
stranded
about a hundred million dollars of cargo
weighing 68 300
tons including coal
iron ore and grain were lost
the storms that impacted many cities
including duluth been there chicago been
there cleveland been i've bombed in all
of those cities
i was the second coming
of the white hurricane in a bad way
um
anyway
79 mile per hour minutes i had no idea
i'd never heard of [ __ ] like that and
probably because
you know everybody knows what's coming
now
you know i kind of have this theory now
that accents are going away
because everybody's just sort of talking
like everybody everybody on the internet
everybody's doing what everybody's doing
right as i have i still have my accent
but that's just because i'm a [ __ ] i've
been out here long enough but generally
speaking
i kind of feel like they're gonna go
away at some point everybody's just
going to talk like a news reporter
i am from alabama hmm
i am from illinois and i am from
massachusetts
you have to to tell the truth to figure
it out
um all right let's get on to what i want
to talk about
watch what
crappin's
live that's what i want to talk about
watch what crap is live
is a uh
is a podcast that basically makes fun of
um
the real housewives and all of that [ __ ]
right so my wife or my wife
always listens to it
so
i was like all right
you know it's in the car
i'm trying to be easier
to get a you know to get along with
you know so you know
i'll listen to this [ __ ] and i started
listening to it these two guys
were [ __ ] funny as hell ben and
ronnie and they basically go on there
and they just recap what has happened on
these real housewives shows
and they imitate everybody on the it's
like snl
for real housewives and uh
i gotta admit i don't i don't even know
what they're talking about 90 of the
time but they're both so [ __ ] funny
i've just started listening to it so
long story short they were doing what uh
watch what crappin's uh next
um
whatever watch what happens i've always
always [ __ ] it up
they were performing at a theater
downtown in l.a so nia goes you know i
was gonna bring one of my girlfriends
she can't make it do you want to go and
i was like yeah i'll go she's like are
you sure she always has to make sure i'm
not gonna [ __ ] things up
because she loves these guys so i'm like
yeah no i'll go down there i'll have a
great time i'd love to go
watch a show and not have to do a show
right so i get in there
right bunch of broads no kidding those
that's waldo wall women basically
and i got to tell you something man they
were going
[ __ ] nuts
it was like uh i i highly recommend
doing this stepping into a world that
you are paying no attention to
and just seeing and watching like
fanatics
of it because these two guys came out
and like i said i was watching the show
i probably only got about 15
to 20 percent of the jokes but still
just watching
their performance
they basically as far as i could tell
they have like bullet points
all right
this is a comedian i was just fascinated
with it they seemed like they had bullet
points on what they wanted to talk about
and then they would just sort of improv
on it and they both had all of their
impressions down
and they never stepped on each other
they did like a two-hour show
they were absolutely destroying and then
they were doing some of the more popular
characters the crowd would start
clapping the second they did them like
uh
like when you would watch snl and
there's like a popular character and you
know who comes in like halfway through
the sketch right
so um
i gotta tell you man i had a [ __ ]
blast at that show and
the woman next to me like these women
were going off man
she drank like the woman next to me
passed out
like i was hanging out with bartnik or
something she went that hard she passed
out under her husband's shoulder
like
at a live podcast i mean i never like
she was like tailgate level drinking it
was [ __ ] awesome
and um
i don't know if you get a chance to see
those guys live or check out their
podcast it's called uh watch what
crappin's next
and um
you know my favorite impressions they do
are the new jersey ones
because east coast people are just
inherently hilarious i don't know why
probably because we're all a bunch of
meat heads or whatever but when they do
them that's like one of my favorites
and then when they
imitate aunt uh andy cohen
um i love that one too and uh and then
there was a couple that i don't know
like the other ones i didn't know but
they were just funny as hell man they're
uh
so whatever so if you're like me and
your wife goes hey do you want to go see
this [ __ ] i i highly recommend going
there
and uh what's great is if you want you
can go there and booze and you will not
be the drunkest person there
because uh
they were getting after it and they were
like
like like halfway through the show like
the women were just like just [ __ ]
talking
and they they sort of plowed right
through it when like they were still
killing
over the top of it and uh
i don't know i i really really enjoyed
it
[ __ ] hilarious
absolutely [ __ ] hilarious so there
you go that's
promoting that and also
to bring it back around to myself
um
i got a really small part and a really
big movie really big shoe uh dog
starring channing tatum channing tatum
is out right
now channing tatum plays
a uh i don't know if he's a veteran he's
a member of the armed services
all right and he's got this dog and he's
got to get you know it's like get him to
the greek with a dog
basically i think i don't know
um
but definitely go see that uh it looks
it looks hilarious you know
who doesn't love dogs who doesn't love
channing tatum and who doesn't love a
bald orange man showing up ever so
briefly just to tease you
tease you with with a dash of ginger
towards the end of it check that out
it's uh it's out now in the u.s i don't
know if you live other places i don't
know it's it's all coming out this week
so check it out i got to work with him
he was cool as [ __ ]
uh great guy and gave me a box of cigars
so
shout out to him and then also we have
uh
the anything better podcast me and paul
ferzi episode 53 is up it's available on
youtube and wherever you find
your podcasts
all right
i think i handled everything
was that it yeah i think that that was
it i'm still i am still i am still
trying to get my wife to come on the
podcast
to talk about some [ __ ]
um to talk about some [ __ ] that i want
to talk about but there's no way i can
[ __ ] talk about it unless she's here
to defend herself so what i think it's
gonna be is it's gonna be a little
tragedy plus time
all right because i asked her tonight
i asked her tonight i was like i was
like honey you want to come on the
podcast and talk about that little
incident
she's like no
i'm like all right
she's like i'm actually a little
offended that you want to talk about it
i was like all right
well i started to talk about it on the
podcast with versey and i had him delete
it
she's like why would you want to talk
about it i go because it's [ __ ]
hilarious so i'll work on her i work on
her and and and eventually
i'll get her uh i'll get her to come
around um
so anyway i actually had a really good
weekend
a buddy of mine my old boss from back in
the day when i used to work in this
warehouse
was out here
with his wife and family and uh i got to
hang out with them
and just talk about the [ __ ] old days
which i cannot believe
i work with this guy from 1986
to 1990.
no 1989
i believe
and i was just thinking back like
like how many years is it 20 25 years
like oh my god
that's 36 years ago [ __ ]
[ __ ] um anyway
so we hung out
and uh
he's the exact same [ __ ] guy he was
you know
i like to think i am too we just pick
every time i see him we just pick up
right where we left off hanging out just
laughing having a great time and
eventually the conversation comes around
to something that is a sports fan i will
always regret
you know one day
you know he came walking out to the
warehouse
area where i was with all the other
animals shipping [ __ ] software and
stuff
uh and he goes hey
he goes i got an extra ticket for the
bruins versus the whalers and hartford
um i asked somebody else
you know but do you want to
he hasn't got back to me
and uh if he doesn't get back to me do
you want to go and i was like
yeah
uh i i'd love to go i don't know why the
[ __ ] i never went to a [ __ ] whalers
game it was right there and i had a car
i just never did it
it just seemed like a million miles away
then of course the other guy who was
also he was a good [ __ ]
um he ended up taking the ticket at the
last second and i didn't get to go and
then i don't know you know a couple
years goes by next thing you know
i don't know
i'm [ __ ] doing stand-up
i leave the job
i never go to a whalers game and then
they move
to carolina
and there's no more hartford whalers
ever again
it kills me
as far as like places i didn't go as a
hockey fan that i never went to see a
whalers game i didn't go to the odd in
buffalo
and i didn't go up to uh whatever the
stadium was i mean this would have been
a road trip and a half
i never went up to where the quebec
nordiks played
like i should have done an atoms
division
um
road trip
i did make it to a montreal canadiens
game
at the uh the place before this place
that they're playing in which wasn't
their original place there was their
second one
um i went to that one
the old month the second forum
fabulous forum
um i did go up there
you know in the 80s
during the second golden age
of hockey but um
i know i talked about this [ __ ] before
but that that's back when the level of
[ __ ] hatred
[ __ ]
hatred
in your division it was just it was like
everybody was just so close together
you know what i mean
the patrick division was the greatest
i mean you could drive to like all of
those [ __ ] teams other than
pittsburgh
long island drive into manhattan
long island you see the islanders drive
into manhattan see the rangers
go through the lincoln tunnel and
[ __ ] come out and go see the uh the
new jersey devils drive down to philly
to the spectrum i would have loved to
see the 76ers there right
all right
go see the flyers down to dc to see the
capitals
and the only one that was [ __ ] odd
man out was the pittsburgh penguins
six hour drive away from uh to philly
five and a half whatever
all depends if the [ __ ] cops are out
or not dude
um
yeah so i was getting caught up with him
and i was writing with my buddy who's
also another
boston guy and we were just talking
about movies and [ __ ]
um
and we're talking about what a big deal
ratings were back in the day
you know
like directors wanted to get a rated pg
if they got a rated r
like that really affected the box office
and they used to fight with sensors and
all of that or they'd take something out
or switch words around in the script so
they could get a pg
because then you know more families
would come more families more tickets
more box office
you know and then they could keep you
know
doing blow up in their [ __ ] hollywood
hills
home as they try to figure out what's
the next movie
and i remember when i was a kid after a
while if it wasn't rated r i wouldn't
even go to the movie
i had no [ __ ] interest in it i'm just
like these this isn't going to be good
this is going to be fake and it's going
to have a happy ending
and uh
we were joking around about how
people used to say
in in massachusetts it was rated ah
raided ah
i can't even say
forget about dropping
ours we couldn't even say r
it was ah
q i s
[Music]
dude let's go my dude my parents took me
to see a [ __ ] rated r movie this
weekend
raided out
rated ah
oh god
i really do love where i'm from
and if i didn't have kids i swear to god
and if i could survive in this business
uh i would definitely really consider
going back there
like i think i don't know what it is i
think that that weekend i had last year
that weekend the 10 days i spent back
there i'm at least gonna do that every
year
and my game plan
is to uh you know take my kids back and
go to red sox games and get them rooting
for the right teams
you know but you know if they start
rooting for la teams i'm not gonna fight
it uh
unless it's the lakers i mean i i can't
have that
so how i combat it as i bring them back
once a year we'll go to a sporting event
in the summertime and then i get all
four sports packages
and i don't force it on them i just
watch bruins celtics patriots and red
sox games out here so hopefully
eventually
they get into that
oh my god that would [ __ ] crush me
that would [ __ ] crush me
oh the lakers
oh my god
somehow they've almost eclipsed
i don't know i wouldn't say the yankees
or the canadians those are the big three
though you know football's another deal
you know what i mean even if my one of
my kids became a colts fan
i just think like johnny united i think
the real cults the baltimore cults
you know not when they moved out to
indianapolis and got the sniffles and
started complaining every time they lost
in the playoffs
that's not legal
yes it is well it shouldn't be
um
anyway uh
i don't know
but anyway getting back to it i feel
like uh
yeah but also i go back there during the
summer so it's great i'm not sitting
there right now in the misery
the [ __ ] misery of january and
february
uh shout out to anybody in the snowy
cities
you're almost out of it
all right we're going to the march in
like a lamb out like a lion dude um
i don't miss that i do not miss january
to february
through february those [ __ ]
you know 59 to six every once in a while
60 days when you get a leap year
do not miss that
at all
but uh i will tell you this
we were scouting some locations
okay i know that sounds hollywood but
that's what we were doing
which just means you're looking at
places to possibly shoot
the [ __ ] that you wrote
and uh we went out to a casino
in in uh the middle of the desert
and uh
place ended up being great and we were
there
like you know we showed up like i don't
know probably around noon
and it was during the week and it wasn't
the holidays
so all it was was all like these
snowbirds out there all these old people
and uh
i got to tell you something man they
made retirement
look really good because these were like
people that were still drinking
you know
they weren't getting hammered but you
know they had like their [ __ ] rob roy
or whatever an old-fashioned whatever
their [ __ ] drink was
and i really realized the importance
that when you get old
and your kids move out and all of that
there has to be you need another old
couple
in your life that you can go hang out
with
because i saw
like these four top tables and there
would be two old guys and two old women
and they were hanging out and they were
just laughing
having a great
time and they were just part of that
generation where you just you know
they're just eating
how they always ate and they're still
having drinks and [ __ ]
and uh
this i don't know there's something
really to be said about that i was just
thinking like the only thing that sucks
about that you you have to
wait for some reason to be that old to
enjoy that life
you know
if anything
makes me want to be smart
and not [ __ ]
be an idiot with finances
is like i when i look at that [ __ ] like
i would love
[ __ ] love to do that
at like 65 just become like semi-retired
you know what i mean and then just be
that guy walking around with that [ __ ]
eating grin on your face
because you don't give a [ __ ] you know
what are you doing today i'm gonna go
out and get the paper
i actually have time to read the paper
can you imagine you know i went into a
uh
a
bodega to get a cream soda i swear to go
i wanted a root beer and they didn't
have it so a w makes a cream soda so i
was like all right at first i thought it
was the root beer i was excited but it
was a cream soda underrated cream soda
you know which it's a little too sweet
i'll be honest with you it's kind of
like me it's a little sweet um
so anyway
um
i went in there and the guy had like
newspaper racks i was like oh do you
sell the paper and he's like nah
nah we stopped selling it four years ago
he's like we just used the old newspaper
racks to keep people away from the
counter because of the covid [ __ ]
and i was like oh all right all right
and i was like oh that sucks
there's just there's nothing better
part of being an old man you got to have
a newspaper right
you got to have it rolled up you know
smacking your pets on the snout
poking your grandkids in the chest i
said you got
you been in the ice box enough now sam
god damn it
i grew up near the great lakes
the white hurricane you ever hear it
um
yeah
i think all of this [ __ ] just when i
think about retiring or or moving back
to massachusetts or just sitting on a
porch and drinking myself to death
that's my brain's dysfunctional way of
saying bill you need a vacation
[Music]
[Laughter]
i know that sounds [ __ ] up but i kind
of figured out how my brain works my
brain
is all or nothing
it's why i had to stop boozing
and you know make sure my other bad
habits you know stay in check because
i'm either [ __ ] in it or i'm out of
it so i just have to make sure that i
apply it
to the right thing if i have that all in
thing
with healthy [ __ ]
i'm in shape
i can have a project i can make it
happen
you know what i mean i can make a dream
come true or whatever but if i if it's
the bad [ __ ] then all then all of that
stuff happens
you know
so i think that's just how my brain my
brain can't process bill why don't you
just take a vacation
the brain immediately goes to
i'm [ __ ] retiring from this [ __ ] and
i'm gonna get a little house with a big
back porch
and i'm just gonna stare at some trees
and i'm gonna get a thousand bottles of
bourbon and i'm gonna see if i can
finish all of them before i croak
oh you know bill you could take 10 days
off here or there recharge your
batteries
get some stories rediscover why it is
you do what you do
you could do that right
i don't know i'm [ __ ] up um
anyway it's all it's the nba all-star
weekend everybody
aka the horror olympics
this is when
the the the blue chip gold digging
[ __ ]
fly in to whatever city the game is in
with nothing but thongs and turkey
basters trying to get themselves
impregnated
by these 20-something-year-old and
30-something year old millionaires
and i'll tell you i i will know
that that feminism in the metoo movement
has put their money where their mouth is
when they say that they want equality
and they just want everything to be a
level playing field the day
that they shift their attention
onto women like that and try to help out
those poor nba players who are going to
go out there
see a perfect ass and a [ __ ] racket
titties and and and not know what to do
all right and women what do they do they
blame guys well that's your fault that's
your [ __ ] fault for [ __ ] being
there you know you're thinking with your
dick that's [ __ ] your fault right
none of this shit's there for everything
that we do is our [ __ ] fault
well what were you doing that's your
fault for playing basketball and being
really good at it
um
you'll be hilarious
if i was running the nba well the
players would get mad at me but
once they realized i was just trying to
protect them
and their fortune i would have the nba
all-star game in utah
[Music]
and then i would book him in super super
religious [ __ ]
uh stupid this is just stereotyping utah
like all the mormons would somehow chase
the [ __ ] out you know it's kind of
like planting a garden where you got to
have like
you know the right plants that kind of
work in unison that like attract like
different bugs that then fight each
other so they kill each other and then
your crops grow something like that
i talked to a farmer one time i don't
know there's got to be a way to do that
with mormons and horse
in the nba
uh
all-star game there's got to be like a
triangle offense of like vagina and dick
somewhere in there that we can keep
people separate
and there's just nothing worse as a man
to see another guy go after a dream
make it [ __ ] happen and then lose all
his money to a [ __ ] you know i mean
it's just just not something
that you know if you're truly happy with
your life
that you would want to see
um and that's my take on the nba
all-star game sorry
um
this is how good i've been eating
i've been eating so perfectly this
afternoon i went down a rabbit hole
looking at different recipes for banana
splits
i don't think i've had a banana split
since i had a paper route
40 something [ __ ] years ago for some
reason i was just like well at this
point there's no [ __ ] way
people are still making the banana split
with chocolate vanilla and strawberry
ice cream
at some point i know somebody
guy fieri or or uh uh uh emerald lagasse
somebody bam kicked it up a notch
somebody
must have their own
new take on it and for the life of me i
couldn't find anybody a few people
caramelized the [ __ ]
bananas
but it's still just sort of that like
you know
i mean it looks like a dessert from the
1800s i guess that's when it came out
there's like two cities that actually
fight over who came up with it
kind of let you know the level of
excitement that's going on in both those
cities
[Laughter]
i mean they actually argue over it
there's a place in ohio and then a place
in pennsylvania in pennsylvania
according to historians
about desserts
that's [ __ ] hilarious you mentioned
being a historian
so many fact checks
like desserts like remember that show
pawn stars
by the way one of the most like
just
as far as just misrepresenting an
industry
pawn stars 100 percent
just misrepresented all of that
like i never i was in a pawn shop one
time before i watched pawn stars i was
selling a keyboard if you can believe it
first time i lived in la i had a
sparsely furnished one-bedroom apartment
with just a little keyboard
because i had no musical outlet and i
wasn't going to get by a guitar
because i'd given up on that and i
played drums and i just you can't play
drums in one better apartment so i was
like i'll learn how to play the piano
i swear to god
i was doing that it was a low point in
my life
uh but i was too detached from my
emotions to realize how pathetic my life
was at that point
so anyway i'm moving back to new york
and uh
i'm selling all my [ __ ] and lo and
behold nobody wants the casio keyboard
and there was a pawn shop down the
street
so i went in and i sold it you know and
the guy gave me like nine dollars or
some [ __ ] i don't know what it was and i
was like all right i'm good i'm out
so i left and i've kind of forgot about
that pawn shop but i started watching
pawn stars
and when you watch that
[ __ ] show you get this idea that
you're gonna go down there
and in that pawn shop is anything from a
[ __ ]
numbers matching muscle car from the
late 60s
to a super bowl ring
and the reality is you walk in and it's
just a bunch of [ __ ]
it's just wall to [ __ ] wall [ __ ] and
i know
that there are stories out there where
people have found [ __ ] that people
didn't know what they had but i'm
telling you the amount of [ __ ]
that you're gonna have to wade through
it's just it's not even [ __ ] worth it
um
oh by the way congratulations to canada
oh
canada
the women won the [ __ ] gold medal
beating the usa ladies i wish i saw that
game i'm actually a big fan of uh
women's sports believe it or not
unlike women i actually watch women's
sports
i actually
support them women's hockey is great
uh women in the ufc are [ __ ]
incredible women's tennis
uh volleyball for uh the game and uh
other reasons
you know
you can't really count those you can't
count like you know that [ __ ]
like beach volleyball
if you're sitting there with half a
stiffy are you really a [ __ ] fan you
got to be honest i like uh women's
softball to get it back on the [ __ ]
rails
i just love watching those pictures
with that [ __ ] delivery they're right
there fred right to the [ __ ] mit
um i don't know how anybody hits that
[ __ ] um
i like that i like when the [ __ ]
i like when the ringers get up and then
they're facing some chick with some heat
and you get to see the classic battle
power versus power
is she gonna go yard
um
i don't know but women they just i don't
know they just don't uh they just don't
[ __ ]
they don't watch it um
anyway oh we got a new advertiser here
on the podcast
on the podcast here master class
everybody www.masterclass.com
uh with masterclass you can learn from
the world's best minds
uh unlike when you listen to me these
people are actually going to be smart
smart and informed anytime anywhere uh
at your own pace you can learn how to
write from david mamet
or aaron sorkin
i mean the level of information that is
on the internet is just incredible
improv improv improve your cooking
skills with courses from wolfgang puck
and gordon ramsay
learn music i saw this
tom morello has you want to take a
guitar lesson with tom morello they got
that you want to learn about jazz they
got herbie hancock
the guy played with miles davis tony
williams
he he
he played with them all
with over 100 classes from
a range of world-class instructors
uh that you've always wanted to do
that thing you've always wanted to do is
closer than you think immersive learning
experience cinema quality classes that
give you unparalleled access to a
renowned master
such a great idea lessons range from
specifically showing you how to execute
a technique to a master's insights about
their craft that can be translated
across many fields and disciplines yeah
like yeah lewis hamilton
um talks about uh
you know
his mindset for success
learn by doing with sessions by
completing real-world projects following
a hands-on 30-day curriculum with
step-by-step guidance from our
world-class instructors master class is
available on your phone web or smart tv
offering classes on a wide variety of
topics all taught by world-class masters
at the top of their field each class is
broken out into individual video lessons
uh usually around 10 minutes long
my [ __ ] is the uh the music lessons
and cooking
um
it's incredible i got to check out the
gordon ramsay ones i like uh not only do
i like the way he cooks i like the stuff
that he cooks
members can explore at their own pace
um each class is supported by
downloadable materials lessons recipes
or more
hundreds of videos you want to talk
about just having a great time if you're
worn out from work you go do this get
better at your hobby and who knows maybe
your hobby will come become your job
there uh hundreds of video lessons from
100
plus of today's most
over 100 of today's most brilliant minds
are available anytime anywhere on ios
android
uh desktop apple tv amazon fire tv and
roku
um i would highly recommend if i was
gonna check out anything quest love
tom morello gordon ramsay
uh who else did i see on there
where is it master class i was actually
going through this
you want to learn you want to learn uh
storytelling in hip-hop they got a guy
named naz ringo starr talks drumming
this is all the music things um
carlos santana guitar lesson
if you want to be a dj for you young
kids they got dead mouse does one
timbalen will teach you how to make some
beats who else do they all categories
here are the categories i kind of went
down a rabbit hole on this one
all right let's check out writing
something i'm trying to learn how to do
uh
all right issa ray
who created and starred in her own was
it hbo absolutely crushed that
um
classic writers i don't know any other
aaron sorkin there we go
uh david mamet
judy bloom she's only written a thousand
books
okay i need i need to i need to know
more about writers i didn't recognize
any of that's like i was literally like
i felt like i was back in math class
when i just did that all right that was
a batman let's go food we're going to go
food here you find out what you want to
do
james suckling
thomas keller
i don't know any of these people either
damn it bill come on wolfgang puck i
know roy choi bam
they got everybody on here oh they got
sheila e also talking about how to play
drums or not bill we get it all right
get unlimited access to every master
class and as a as a monday morning
podcast listener you get 15 off an
annual membership go to masterclass.com
burr now that's masterclass.com
for 15 off masterclass
good lord man i clicked on writing that
was just i felt like i was watching
jeopardy
i'll take popular american writers for
1500.
do you know somebody sent me a uh a
video
um
a clip
i was the answer i couldn't believe it
this is like a moment
in your
entertainment career i was the answer to
a question on jeopardy
and
the guy sends me the clip and i was like
holy [ __ ]
they were like this comedian's last that
last name begins with b was one of the
people on is for family i'm like holy
[ __ ] and then they go to three of the
smartest people ever
and they just sat there staring at the
guy and it's like
then they got it wrong
so all my excitement went out the window
it's like bill you were an answer on
jeopardy but nobody knew the end no one
knew who you were
all right let's read some of the uh
some of the stories here for this week
uh dumb
criminal story
dear billy scarlet scrotum burr i love
it
uh
love the show love all you do this is my
dumb criminal story i live in the great
white north and living in british
columbia
the drinking age is 19. wait what i live
in the great white north and living in
british columbia
i'm so stupid all i saw was columbia and
i was thinking south america okay
british columbia canada
[Music]
what happened to the men's team
um
it's one of the provinces
vancouver
is in british columbia
right okay
anyway the drinking age is 19. so my
buddies and i figured out figured we'd
go to alberta
at 18 to party in downtown calgary i can
tell you right now that's a mistake dude
calgary
is a drink in town i would not go there
and they got like [ __ ]
those are cattle people
you could get i i would think you could
get seriously
[ __ ] up if you looked at the wrong
cowboy like i always looked at alberta
like this is texas
you know it's oil fields and [ __ ]
you know cattle and then i feel like
edmonton is like the austin
of like alberta where they think that
they're better than everybody else out
there that's what i feel all right
anyway ish this [ __ ] comes up to us
with a knife while we waited to get into
this into the show we were going to
buddy ass i love when they say that
that's no that's canadian buddy buddy
asked me
what do you think of this and flash me
the knife i told him i'd give him 50
bucks for it wow
look at you [ __ ] just coming up with
a steven seagal no line
oh i thought he was pulling the knife on
you
i thought the guy pulled a knife on you
like what do you think of this
and you say i'll give you 50 bucks for
it
no i'm mugging you all right buddy gives
me the knife i throw it in the trash
beat the [ __ ] wheels off him and took
my money took back my money wait a
minute
this really happened well there goes my
theory on calgary
one of my favorite stories to tell
anyway hope you found it as funny as i
did have a great day and go [ __ ]
yourself
okay i i when he said what do you think
of this was he trying to mug you
buddy asked me what do you think of this
and flash me the knife i told him i give
him 50 bucks for it buddy gives me the
knife i throw it in the trash beat the
[ __ ] wheels off him and took back my
money
you definitely don't live in vancouver i
didn't get that vibe in vancouver but
you're are you north of the city
the moral of the story is uh don't pull
a knife on anybody in [ __ ] canada
lunatics
lunatics everybody thinks they're
[ __ ] nice up there look at the sport
they created and know that fighting is
legal
oh they're so nice and polite
um all right
22.
22 caliber robbery story
dear billy bumble butt on a recent
podcast you asked for robbery stories i
got one for you that i think you'll
appreciate especially given your old bit
about how a 22 caliber is all you need
years ago i worked on a construction
crew with two old guys who were best
buds and had worked together for years
in the dc area uh one black one white
charlie a 70 year old white guy told me
a story about jimmy with an eye like
hendricks a 69 year old black guy jimmy
owned a car repair garage in dc in the
70s one day a white guy came in and
stuck a gun in his face and demanded his
cash from the register jimmy not wanting
any trouble opened the till and handed
it over but after the robber took the
money
he called jimmy a nasty name i will not
repeat here i imagine and hit him across
the head with his revolver before
running out the door this pissed jimmy
off so he grabbed a 22 pistol from under
the counter and went after the guy
he caught up with him in the parking lot
and shot him in the leg with the 22. the
guy crawled under a car
as charlie told me in his thick virginia
accent
jimmy was there trying to shoot him
again
the police showed up and arrested both
of them
the white robber did a year in jail and
jimmy being a black guy in dc in the 70s
had to do a few months himself for
shooting a white guy
wow after about a year or two jimmy is
back at work at his garage and who
should walk in but the [ __ ] robber
he walked up to jimmy and said hey i
just wanted to let you know i'm out of
jail now
jimmy looked him square in the face and
said well i just want to let you know i
got rid of my 22 and i now got a 38. the
guy backed out of the place and jimmy
never had any more trouble from him
wow well i was hoping for a happy ending
i just got out of jail and i want to say
you know i should have called you that
word i shouldn't
i'm on the straight and narrow and i'm
looking for a job um
wow
that's a couple of men man stories right
there i ca i can't follow any of those
i got all right i got a robbery story i
got punked out of some money
at um
downtown crossing downtown [ __ ]
crossing in boston
in the early 80s doing christmas
shopping in front of long's jewelry
they just punked me out of the money
they said that they needed money for the
subway and then his tall friend
who looked like [ __ ] weird harold
from uh fat albert goes you better do
what he says i just gave him the money
that [ __ ] bugged the [ __ ] out of me
but like rather than just taking the ass
kicking
you know
in hindsight i did the right thing
because i was going to lose
santa robs a bank
hey there billy ball bruiser uh i'll get
straight to the point we're all busy a
few years back during santa con
santa con
a santa robbed a bank wait a second
is this like comic-con but with santa
clauses
so there's a bunch of santas walking
around so a guy dressed this is that's
brilliant
sanikon
sanikon 2021 brings out oh my god it's a
bunch of [ __ ] jerk-offs dressed like
santa
okay it is all right
a few years back during santa claus con
a santa robbed a bank
what is sanicon you ask santa con is a
day where a bunch of idiots dress like
santa claus and bar hop all day and
night
all right
are they idiots i mean that sounds like
fun
if you just go in there like oh ho ho i
love christmas and you're standing there
sweating your ass off in that dumb
outfit but once you if you're just bar
hopping that seems great
and you know there's going to be some
chicks out there that's going to be a
fetish then you got the little santa
clausettes showing up
i mean whatever you know it's holidays
is it is it just for kids i don't think
so uh well this particular sanikon one
smart santa out of all the idiots
hatched a genius plan he dressed as
santa walked out of a huge crowd of
santas on the street
and into a downtown san francisco bank
he pulled his beard slightly down and
waited in line when he got to the teller
he handed her a note that said he was
armed and to empty the drawer
he grabbed a few stacks of cash put it
in his santa bag to walk back out on the
street as to instantly blend in with
thousands of other centers [ __ ]
genius they never got him
you can google this story
even with your remedial googling skills
hey man come on
all right open the link
santa this is in the la times
doesn't necessarily mean it's true with
those [ __ ] lunatics or any of them i
should say
uh
at least
one santa claus in san francisco is not
carrying a sack full of toys it's
december 16th 2014.
good for him
good for him all right attempted robbery
hey oli
hey hey old billy bank robber
back in 2020 my wife and i were on
vacation together down in orlando and
went over to daytona for a couple of
nights for a nascar ride-along at the
speedway and to check out the area when
we got there we went into a subway for a
quick lunch and while we were sitting
and eating this guy walks in with a
hoodie
hoodie up
a gator mask on
and hand in his pocket like he has a gun
he says to two teenagers working there
give me all the money
they stood back and told the guy he
needed to leave he proceeded to threaten
them
and keep saying to give up the money but
they didn't and could care less what he
was doing after a minute or so the
manager comes out back with the mop and
says
willie you get out of here the robber
responds i'm not willy you need to give
me all the money the manager then starts
to come around the counter saying you
get the [ __ ] out of here i'm gonna bust
your head willie says okay fine just
give me a cold-cut trio and no one gets
hurt i almost died laughing
then realized my wife was terrified i
assumed that
they knew the guy based on their
reaction to begin with my wife clearly
did not
willy left without a sandwich and the
manager came over and apologized says
that's just a crackhead that comes in
and is harmless if he bothers you when
you leave just tell him to go away or
you'll beat his ass we ended up going
back to the speedway
for my ride-along and then she got a
refund on the hotel room and we drove
back to orlando i'll never forget the
look on her face as i busted out
laughing when i heard him ask for a
sandwich
still to this day whenever she pulls the
typical wife what do you feel like
having for dinner i respond with just
give me a cold-cut trio that's awesome
big fan love the podcast my six-year-old
son and i have watched every mandalorian
episode multiple times and you are great
in it well thank you so much and thank
you to everybody over at the mandalorian
that writes the mandalorian because
without them
i'm just a guy in a space outfit um
all right moved in with girlfriend and
gained 30 pounds oh jesus
jesus now you can't leave
hey bill a long time listener i need
help here i used to be a crossfitter i
love how i looked
it wasn't to
attract women but it was more for myself
i loved the feeling of having a body
that wasn't being
weighed down by fat it was amazing later
i moved in with my girl stopped doing
crossfit why did you stop
because oh because that's a 200 a month
and bills
took the front of it oh
back to her she has always been the
chubby nerdy type girl i love her tips i
love her tits captivated me from the
beginning but she also is about 30
pounds overweight
you guys couldn't meet in the middle and
just be 15 over in the beginning i
thought i could change it but she
actually changed me ah stano never
underestimated the power of a rack of
titties
um
i started eating like she does and i
gained 30 pounds she will compromise and
go to the gym once a week but she won't
change her eating habits she described
herself as a foodie it's really an
addict you know if you're doing
something like that and it's hurting you
it's a term for someone who loves food
it makes their personality about loving
food and cooking food or some other
people like to call it a fatty exactly
by the way she makes healthy food it's
just that she
eat mindlessly without thinking
mindless like that [ __ ] sentence how
many words are gonna leave out in this
thing bill what what would you do thank
you
uh
and then he says in some language i
don't know
i gotta say the facts
go [ __ ] yourself i just became a
ringtone in like venezuela or some [ __ ]
um
anyway um
what would i do um
well listen if she wants to be fat and
you like her that way she can be fat
30 pounds overweight coming at you with
those nice tits what do you give a [ __ ]
all right i think uh you just don't want
to have the same size you want to be
able to borrow her bras
you know what the same size titties as
her so what i would do is i would just
say listen i'm not going to pressure you
to go i won't even say that i would just
[ __ ] [ __ ] over 200 bucks a month and
start going to crossfit again
all right
that's it
and i keep myself in good shape
and uh
as far as wanting her to get in good
shape and better shape there's nothing
you can do about it you can't make
somebody want to get in shape they have
to want to do it and if they don't
they don't
don't waste your time with that that is
their choice it's
oh my god i [ __ ] hate when i do that
i actually shut it off now i gotta
splice these things together it's her
body her choice man
don't tell her what to do with their
body all right if she wants to [ __ ]
make s'mores
and stick him in an ice cream sandwich
that's on her but um
you don't have to get dragged down to
her level
all right
that's what they always say you got to
watch out who you hang out with because
eventually you're going to be doing what
they that what they're doing
so what maybe if you start going to the
gym if you start setting an example
and just get back into insane [ __ ]
shape again
um
you know
maybe she'll come along with you
but i think it's cool that she you know
you she sounds cool she liked you when
you were in shape she likes you when
you're 30 pounds over so it sounds like
uh
you got a good one there but i would
just um
you know you guys sound like you're
young the thing about that [ __ ] is when
you're young it doesn't really affect
you but it then one day it all comes
crashing down
and you have all of these [ __ ] health
issues and your knees start giving out
and you got to go on pills and then that
[ __ ] with your liver
and it just it just takes you down it
takes you down so
uh i hate to be the [ __ ] old guy here
but good eating habits are important to
establish those when you're younger
um
so then when you get older
you can go out and get a root beer float
and [ __ ] crush some old fashions
you know it's always those little
[ __ ] spry people that keep on living
um
whatever like i said you can't make her
do anything she doesn't want to do it
sounds like you're doing what she's
doing and you don't really want to be
doing it so i'd go back to doing what
you did before
and then that's it it's 200 bucks
[ __ ] it
it's only 200 dollars
you're probably eating [ __ ] 300 worth
of fries a month
all right okay that's it that's the
podcast everybody thank you so much for
listening um
i'm about to get really busy
so i'm gonna do the best i can with
these podcasts i will definitely be
having the monday morning podcast every
week
but for the month of march it's going to
get a little [ __ ] crazy here um
but i'm going to try to knock out as
many as i can
uh that is it i appreciate your support
that is all march madness is coming up
uh start watching some college hoop all
right go [ __ ] yourselves and i'll check
in on you on thursday